suicides are the eighth leading cause of
death in our state and one local
organization is hoping to change the
narrative by providing more help
christian casadas joining us now live
with more on how they're making this
happen and how you can help kristen well
denise the local chapter for the
american foundation for suicide
prevention says on average there are
about 130 suicides per day in the u.s
now to continue the fight they need to
help they need your help to keep all
those resources from running out
suicide is a public health problem and
leading cause of death across the
country according to the american
foundation for suicide prevention they
say it's the eighth leading cause of
death in the state of nevada they're not
acting the way they normally would
you should really have an honest
conversation with that person but make
sure you talk to them in private
listen to them listen to their story
tell them that you care about them the
american foundation for suicide
prevention says this can all be
prevented with education the more we
normalize conversation about mental
health the easier it becomes for people
to reach out and for help and actually
seek the treatment that they need to
keep the aid available the
organization's local chapter is hosting
a fundraiser where each table is honored
by those who have passed away an annual
effort hit hard last year because of the
pandemic we still were able to do some
some great
work in the community
and actually this year we did
our walk this year we raised our goal
and we met our goal of a hundred
thousand dollars this year's goal is 20
thousand dollars a small amount but
enough they say to keep making a
difference in southern nevada visit
8newsnow.com for details
well the organization wants to remind
the community that there is help and
remember you are not alone if you or
someone you know is having suicidal
thoughts please reach out to the
national suicide prevention hotline that
number right there on your screen
christian casa is live local now